[Musik]
ein Glas nach dem anderen glühend heiß
die Maschinen bei duralex stehen nicht
Stille werden rund um die Uhr mit Gas
befeuert
Claris ardi wacht über den Ofen in dem
französischen Traditionsunternehmen das
diesen Winter zum ersten Mal in seiner
Geschichte eine Zwangspause einlegen
muss
das kam für uns alle überraschend und
verunsichert uns natürlich wir können
keine Gläser keine Artikel mehr
herstellen aber bei den hohen
Energiepreisen bleibt uns keine Wahl
die Ausgaben für Energie sind von drei
auf 13 Millionen Euro gestiegen machen
inzwischen etwa die Hälfte des Umsatzes
aus von der ofenmeisterin erfahre ich
dass die Firma bereits den Verbrauch
runtergefahren hat doch die Maßnahmen
reichen nicht spätestens wenn man hier
steht und diese enorme Hitze hautnah
miterlebt wird klar wie viel Energie
hier benötigt wird und das rund um die
Uhr Kosten wie sich das Unternehmen
nicht mehr leisten kann und deshalb
stehen diese Bänder ab November still
von 90 Millionen Gläsern im Jahr mit
einem Mal auf Null nur der Schmelzofen
an sich bleibt dann noch in Betrieb bei
einer Temperatur von 1.300 grad
die Masse ist zu groß die sich im Ofen
befindet wenn wir ihn komplett
abschalten verfestigt Sie sich was den
Tod des Ofens und der Fabrik bedeuten
würde
also müssen wir Ihnen auf einer
minimal-temperatur halten
doch dafür wird längst nicht die
komplette Belegschaft gebraucht sie
langen Chanson und die meisten seiner
250 Kollegen werden im Winter pausieren
müssen und weniger Gehalt bekommen
Kurzarbeit bis Anfang April
wir haben unsere Häuser unsere Familien
das Problem ist dass wir nur 95% unseres
Gehalts bekommen
gleichzeitig wird das Leben teurer der
Sprit alles andere und die fünf Prozent
Gehalt die fehlen das wird sich bei mir
und meinen Kollegen schon auswerten
duralex das Werk in der Nähe von Orlean
ist kein Einzelfall Glashersteller
Stahlwerke Papier und aluminiumfabriken
im ganzen Land müssen Betriebe ebenfalls
ihre Produktion drosseln dabei befindet
sich Frankreichs Industrie ohnehin schon
im Sinkflug durch Abwanderung Pleiten
verpasste Innovation
und so wächst die Angst um die
Arbeitsplätze
[Musik]
Mitte Oktober Generalstreik und Demos
landesweit in Orlean reihen sich
Angestellte von duralex in den
proteststzug ein sie wollen ein Zeichen
setzen
verbesser wäre es uns weiter voll zu
bezahlen denn für den Anstieg der
Energiepreise sind nicht wir Arbeiter
verantwortlich trotzdem leiden besonders
wir darunter
ich arbeite seit 20 Jahren für duralex
es hat seitdem kaum Gehaltserhöhungen
gegeben jetzt ist der Moment unsere
Unzufriedenheit zu zeigen
sie fordern Firmenchefs und Aktionäre
mehr in die Pflicht zu nehmen dass der
Staat immer mehr öffentliches Geld in
die Unternehmen steckt erst in der
Corona und nun in der Energiekrise sehen
sie mit Skepsis denn die Arbeiter würden
davon nicht profitieren
und eines Tages wird macron sagen die
Schulden sind zu hoch es geht nicht so
weiter wir müssen bei den
Sozialleistungen kürzen die Rentenreform
ist unumgänglich das ist die Logik der
Regierung der Weg auf dem wir uns
befinden sie helfen den Reichen immer
reicher zu werden und wir die den
Reichtum erarbeiten werden immer ärmer
deshalb nennen wir Gewerkschaftler
macron auch Präsident der Reichen der
ultrareichen sogar
die Proteste häufen sich seit
Herbstbeginn überall im Land und Sie
werden mehr und mehr zum Stresstest für
die Regierung dabei kann man ja nicht
vorwerfen in der Energiekrise tatenlos
zu sein seit Monaten sind die Strom- und
Gaspreise gedeckelt und doch bleibt
macron und populär das sieht man an den
Streiks in den Raffinerien das sieht man
an den Demos gegen die anstehenden
Sozialreformen und vor allem gegen die
steigenden Kosten viele Französinnen und
Franzosen haben Sorge im Alltag einfach
nicht mehr über die Runden zu kommen
zwar hat Frankreich mit sechs Prozent
eine der niedrigsten Inflationsraten in
Europa doch die Menschen verdienen im
Durchschnitt auch weniger als etwa die
deutschen Nachbarn
wir verlassen eure Leon und fahren aufs
Land
ein Dorf 700 Einwohner in wenigen
Stunden schließt die Backstube von Kevin
und Solin robion sie geben auf ganz
ein Baguette bitte viele Stammkunden
kommen am Nachmittag vorbei um sich von
dem Bäcker zu verabschieden sie können
die Entscheidung nachvollziehen wissen
dass sich sein Geschäft kaum noch lohnt
also dann schönen Abend euch
wir arbeiten in der gleichen Branche ich
weiß wie schwer das ist sind sie
Bäckerin nein Konditorin in einem
größeren Betrieb aber uns allen steht
das Wasser bis zum Hals
leider den kleinen noch mehr als den
großen
das Ehepaar müsste Schulden aufnehmen um
den Betrieb weiterzuführen ein Risiko
dass sie nicht eingehen wollen gerade
jetzt in unsicheren Zeiten erzählt er
mir es sei kaum abzusehen wie sich die
Energiepreise entwickeln
letztes Jahr haben wir 1200 bis 1.400
Euro im Monat bezahlt jetzt liegen wir
bei 3.4000 das geht einfach nicht hinzu
kommen die gestiegenen Preise für die
Zutaten die Kosten können wir nicht auf
den Brotpreis umlegen die Kunden haben
schließlich auch kaum noch was in Ihrem
Geldbeutel
und so sorgt sich Kevin robion auch um
das Handwerk er ist bei weitem nicht der
einzige der dicht machen muss 9000
Firmen haben allein in diesem Sommer
Insolvenz angemeldet die meisten von
ihnen Kleinstunternehmen
das Wissen weitergeben unser Baguette
ist uns heilig in Frankreich was soll
werden wenn es nur noch industriell
hergestellt wird reelle
wenn das so weitergeht wird es das
Handwerk und die kleinen Verkäufer bald
nicht mehr geben
eine Entwicklung die die Menschen auf
dem Land hart trifft denn mit den
kleinen Läden schwinden auch die Jobs
ich melde mich nun arbeitslos und hoffe
dass ich was anderes finde so ist es
halt
keiner weiß was die Zukunft bringt es
hat schon seinen Grund dass im Land so
viel gestreikt wird alles wird teurer
ich weiß ja nicht wie es bei euch in
Deutschland ist aber in Frankreich wird
es immer katastrophale
na vielleicht kommen wir irgendwann
wieder wenn sie aufhören uns das Leben
so schwer zu machen
nicht nur hier stellen Sie sich auf
einen ungemütlichen Winter ein und die
Sorge wächst ob und wann sich das Land
von seinen Krisen erholen kann
Frankreich bankt um seine Industrie und
seine Arbeitsplätze in Großbritannien
fürchtet man sich vor der großen Kälte
viele Britinnen und Briten frieren das
Land steckt mitten in einer Energiekrise
vor allem seit dem Ukraine Krieg erzählt
unser Kollege Andreas Stamm in diesem
Video
in Ländern die nicht Wohlstand kaum
kennen geht es um das tägliche Überleben
wächst die Angst zu verhungern dazu ein
Video hier von meiner Kollegin Susan von
Lojewski sie war im Südsudan unterwegs
wo die Not immer größer wird
lust auf noch mehr Filme dann abonniert
unbedingt unseren Kanal